he's a winner how are you so good to see
you again it's really good to see you
back here it's great to be here I mean
the the one thing you said to me when we
were talking and it it sat with me so
when they we called your name I almost
lost it 38 years you've been dreaming of
being here at the Golden Globes you get
here tonight and look what you get yeah
that's
trip 38 years
um
it feels incredible
um
I I can't believe I'm here
holding this talking to you uh in fact I
was um when I was uh when I was up there
I saw
Steven Spielberg
uh looking at me
and uh and that gave me the greatest joy
because that man gave me my first
opportunity uh and when I finished my
speech I saw him stood up
uh so I got us that elevation from
Steven Spielberg
uh yeah it's been yeah now you said you
would like to link up with him again
maybe did you get to connect with him
yet or was it all has this all been such
a whirlwind have you even gotten this it
has been a whirlwind uh uh I I can't
wait to to go back out there and give
him a big big hug and of course I also
need to give a big big hug to Daniels to
my eao family Michelle Stephanie Jamie
uh uh and everybody and most importantly
my wife who has supported me so happy
yeah she's happy and you know and
honestly this whole journey uh the
greatest joy has been to see how happy
my family has been for me because
they've seen me struggle uh they've seen
me through the tough times and they
never gave up on me so that's what I was
gonna ask you you wanted to do a short
round maybe spin-off for
for any angels with Stephen would you
would you talk to him about that I would
be all for it you know why because I
love that character that character
started my career like that movie
changed my life it was the first time in
the history of Cinema that a big
director put an Asian face up on the big
screen uh and and so I will always love
that character Short Round And if you
ask me to revisit that character I would
do it any day hey let's get this pitched
together what are we doing let's get
those guys together all you gotta do is
walk up put this on the table and say
Short Round
yeah right that's all you have to do
yeah yeah so I saw when you walked in
Michelle yo won and you ran right over
to the monitor to watch because I love
Michelle yo of course there is no
everything everywhere all at once
without her uh she's our matriarch she's
our leader and she has let the entire
family with such Grace and and and love
uh and beauty and uh yeah I'm so
grateful to her uh so tonight yeah I I'm
so happy yeah that's all I'd ask you
when this night is over and you get a
chance to sit down by yourself with that
trophy what goes through your mind you
know everything is a blue right now I
kid you now when they read my name in
fact I I everything was blurry uh I
didn't know what I was feeling uh but
hopefully when all of this is settled uh
you know I I realize like I said earlier
it's been 38 years this stream has been
in 38 years making
um and yeah Angela Bassett was back here
and she said that you said to her you
guys are forever connected because it's
been 30 years for her too that you
always are going to have that bond that
dream of decades-long dream yes we would
be always we will always be bonded by
tonight and then also by MCU family
because recently I joined the MSU family
on Loki season two come on Loki season
two okay tell me all about it because
I'm an MCU nerd trying to get him fired
be patient for just a few more months oh
can I tell you something you can tell me
anything yes in the beginning in in the
okay hold on okay so this is really cool
uh before the show started I went up and
I and I gave Jamie Lee Curtis a hug and
she says key and give me your hand
and she placed something in my hand that
I didn't know what it was and she said
he
if you don't win tonight
I don't want you to go home empty-handed
and guess what she placed in my hands
let's see
a little Globe oh wow isn't she sweet
yes yes this is what this is what Jamie
Lee Curtis gave me before the show
started
uh and now I have two Globes
yeah she's a gym I will treasure this uh
forever yeah so yes yeah you
party yes okay yes I I can't wait to
drink
hold on hold on we have champagne here
we have champagne back here earlier so
we gotta have one we got
a whole Champion we're gonna get you
some shampoo
here it comes
that was a good luck toast earlier so
now we gotta finish the job yes
and by the way I've always been a fan of
E.T always been a fan well we appreciate
it and uh and and you know I always I
always again I mean I haven't been I
haven't been doing this for so long so I
I can't believe that I'm talking to you
guys again
so it is great to sit here across from
you knowing the journey and what it
means to you you know it's something
special we get to share moments like
this all right here we go and that's why
we need the toast to two glows there we
go cheers
[Music]